salut aujourd'hui je suis avec les
tissages de droits de garde et issia ton
est donné ton adresse
ceci étant pourquoi pas ça fait savoir
si vous voulez mais envoyer des
courriers des cadeaux d'être comme ça
vous pouvez donc on sait que j'avais
même pas français
déjà des cadeaux des mains et lætitia
les pages youtube qui s'appelle le corps
la maison détruite et un blog qui
s'appelle encore la maison il fallait
une attitude qui s'appelle c'est comme
ça qu'on s'est rencontré et javacard
tunnel de nantes au web ici ici et là au
fond vous voyez ce que regardent les
riches à un moment donné mais le
spectacle parle de simplicité
parce que c'est une notion que j'aime
bien la musique est ce un hasard
remarquable ça veut dire qu'il ya
quelque chose qui se passe c'est un peu
surprenant et ça tue le remarque
c'est une cérémonie réussie liée non pas
de rentrer dans ton esprit aux arrivées
de deux avec sa chronicité à l'aide des
rubik's cube c'est toujours fascinant
lhermitte cube parce qu'on ne sait pas
le faire une fois qu'on sait le faire on
trouve ça facile mais c'est tellement
facile que dans les concours aux
mondiaux de rubik's cube
ils ont trouvé comment vous pouvez
départager ces champions faisant des
petites cartes comme ça sont des cartes
ou en fait il ya un véhicule mais qui
n'est pas fait dans le bonheur et ça
c'est plus compliqué pour un mail
domicile de faire ces gens ordinaires
l'inquiétude japon prend les tripes de
rubik's cube sont pas des bases
classiques donc là on peut plus utiliser
les méthodes mathématiques la cible pour
les départager après piocher dans cette
carte et l'offre résoudre ça en moins de
temps possible et j'ai été associé à la
notion de synchronicité c'est à dire que
moi et j'ai pris une photo d'un objectif
c'est de nantes dans cette magnifique
qu'est ce qui se passe si tu te
concentres sur une enveloppe et du
piocher carte est ce que tu as quelque
chose qui ressemblait ce qu'on avait
même dominante est son ami identique et
ce qui se passe quelque chose de
surprenant point qu'on puisse dire que
je suis très lucide on va essayer qui va
mélanger les cas que les mélanges
démarche proactive et légumes cultivés à
tous les besoins de chaque fois pourquoi
les gens font front commun
je suis pas les mélanges sans le relever
de sitôt car je m'en fiche complètement
mais c'est intéressant dit ok je sais
pas comment je dis ce qu'il ya dedans
c'était dur pose exactement
est ce que tu peux encore une anglaise
que tu veux couper est ce que tu veux
qu'on s'arrête là puisque tu mon copain
est ce que tu veut regrouper ou alors
j'ai fait tout ce que tu voulais 3g
tellement déprimant la première carte de
la retourner
jusqu'ici sur la côte est donc ça c'est
cette image là j'aime bien qu'à pouvoir
elle ressemble à ça c'est la carte soit
appliquée avec l'air d'avoir mélangé
payer du tout donc on a soif une hernie
par exemple du verre durant schibler que
du plan de coin du jaune du bleu du vert
des yeux rouges
dans cette enveloppe il ya une photo
imagine si affaibli ni l'ange xo
il ya 2000 identique ce sera une pause a
profité aussi à tout le tour est
peut-être celui du sang qui change
on va voir le nombre de points communs
c'est entre la caf et ma photo attaque
alors si on m'a fait toucher une seule
chose c'est que le orange est mal pris
donc j'ai réécrit orange mois sur martin
girling j'ai juste comme ça du bleu du
orange fait divers ça c'est la première
fois la deuxième ligne
j'avais vu lundi dans l'edition voisine
ping je dis heureusement arrêté sur la
même carte que la photo que j'avais
prévenu à l'adresse dans leur enveloppe
évidemment je t'aime
il n'y a pas de trucage mais comment
c'est possible voitures arrêtées sur
elle c'est pas pareil
cet appareil assure être aussi son
enveloppe
photo ll la carte cadeau tu pourras dire
maintenant j'ai réussi à faire quelque
chose avec un rubik's cube un jour non
mais attention notre fonctionnement il
m'en fous pas vous faire mais moi je
fais des trucs du coup avec la rédaction
je savais quelle carte correspondant
mais parfois la mélanger à triper je te
proposait de le tacler à plusieurs
moments de paix continue sa décharge
n'ya que là je comprends pas un truc de
fou ok merci merci à toi merci je
rajoute à va rencontrer vraiment ravi
qu'il soit mieux peut-être aller voir sa
chaîne il ya des trucs de poule sur le
zéro déchet sur l'écologie sur eux
comment être bien dans sa tête et dans
son corps et dans sa maison tatou bien
résumé je vois ta musique 11 octobre
j'espère que ça ne faisait plus
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
c'est super important
n'hésitez pas à commenter à dire ce que
vous en avez pensé si vous voulez revoir
laetitia et à demain 17h
canalblog chao et tu peux même s'il est
admis que tu veux sur mon album poussins
gia tchad